meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft facts sich einige gefragt
haben hey wieso kam er so lange keine
folge ich war wirklich die ganze zeit
damit beschäftigt effekt rauszusuchen
also jetzt nicht die ganze zeit aber auf
jeden fall eine menge also immer als ich
mir wirklich dachte hey du kannst du
eigentlich mit den folgen der minecraft
aufnehmen saß ich in stunde ungelogen
habe einfach nach fakten gesucht und
fand einfach keine vernünftige und ich
habe jetzt auch wieder nur so ein paar
komische deswegen freunde viele würden
wir würden ihm mögen und lieben ja diese
serie und sachfragen mich ganz oft
danach so harry wann kommt er denn mal
wieder und so es liegt quasi daran dass
mir die fed so ein bisschen ausgeben die
interessant sind es gibt unendlich
fakten in minecraft aber es gibt nicht
unendlich was macht deshalb in manama es
gibt aber einfach nicht unendlich
interessante fakten in minecraft und ich
habe jetzt endlich auch mal den shader
reingekommen
das sieht hier einfach so toll aus mit
ist und deswegen an dieser stelle eine
kleine aufforderung an euch freunde so
eine art hausaufgabe ihr sucht jetzt
alle mal in minecraft infekt raus oder
zumindest wenn ihr schon fag habt
einfach hier in die kommentare schreiben
weil da werde ich mir dann auf jeden
fall wenn ich in zukunft noch mehr
effektvoll machen soll auf jeden fall
immer alle möglichen kommentare und
facts und alles was ihr habt in die
kommentare brettern damit ich da genug
auswahl habe damit ich auch genug cool
effect vorstellen kann
weil in zukunft wird die facts folge auf
nur noch dienstags kommen ich habe
beschlossen dass freitag setzten die
komanis folge kommt und allgemeiner
zwischendurch kommen weil die command
habe ich einfach so zehn millionen ich
möchte gar nicht mehr weiter hier zum
reden also einfach wenn ihr es wisst
einfach alles den kommentare schreiben
damit ich eine größere auswahl ab und
damit öfter defekts kommen und dann
fangen wir direkt an mit fact nummer
kennt ja alle diese fledermäuse und zwar
wenn ich die herren landesbahnen dann
fliegen die halt einfach wild in der
gegend rum und so weiter und so fort und
die kennt es auch mit sicherheit wenn
ich irgendwie ein mob ins wasser packe
es gibt ein paar mops die ertrinken dann
einfach nach derzeit unter wasser und es
gibt doch mops die einfach so ganz
logischer weise einfach danach nach oben
schwimmen
wenn ich allerdings eine fledermaus mal
irgendwie hierunter wassers tonne seht
ihr die fliegt hier genauso dumm rum wie
auch härter normalen luft die stellt
keine anstalten an ihm wie nach oben zu
kommen die hat kein überleben sind oder
irgendwie sowas
und gleich seht ihr die wird einfach
verrecken um kleine fledermaus stirbt
doch einfach sterben versterben will
guckt ihr seht schon die fliegt die
ganze drum seine behinderte und jetzt
ist die einfach gestorben ich habe jetzt
noch mal eben so ein paar mehr
fledermäuse gesponnen und zwar einfach
fledermäuse beleben sich unter wasser
genauso wie an anderen ihr seht schon
die verrecken einfach und die fliegen
hier einfach um als wären sie wirklich
an land und die stellen keine anstalten
an mal irgendwie vielleicht müssten wir
mal atmen oder sony die fliegen einfach
unter wasser genau so weiter bis die
dann irgendwann elendig sterben weg
nummer zwei ist ein fact bestehend aus
zwei facts ich finde das immer noch um
das schön mit dem schneider ammann und
zwar ist es ein fact über schafe uns war
sagt dass minecraft wiki das ist eine 81
prozentige chance ist wenn man einen
einen schaaf spornt das ist weiß ist
eine 5 prozentige chance dass das
schwarz ist 5 prozent grau 5% hellgrau
3% braun und pink 0,16 vier jetzt jemals
ein paar schafe spawnen seht ihr hier
schon da kommt ab und zimmer so schwarz
da kommt ein grauer ist das glaube ich
sogar hellgrau jetzt kommt man wieder
mal grau ist einfach nach dieser dings
und irgendwann bei einer chance von also
jedes tausendste scharf ca ist ein
pinkes scharf also wer so oft wirklich
drückt bis man ein pinkes schaaf hat der
hat echt irgendwie langweilig hofft noch
so die ganze zeit das irgendwann
gleichen pink geschaffen kommt und ich
euch das mal demonstrieren kann aber es
wird einfach kein big geschafft kommen
und ich habe schon alles voll mit
schafen etwa hier muss auch jemand mal
so ein pinkes kommen als ob ich okay ich
habe jetzt vielleicht auch erst 200 mal
drauf guckt dabei ich bin ich immer
glücklich an menschen die mich neugierig
geblieben
das ist nicht wahr ich hab's euch doch
gesagt dass man vielleicht so 200 schafe
die chance liegt bei jedes tausendste
scharf welcher titel
linke-chef finden wo mein gott wie krank
ist das denn bitte ich glaube ihr habt
es gesehen dass ich einfach dieses
bonner hier genommen und einfach so das
ist aber auch gar nicht der effekt also
das ist einfach nur so eine kleine notiz
am rande und der andere fällt der in dem
zweiten fed auch noch mit drin ist ist
egal welche farbe von einem schaf ich
jetzt hier einfach basiere diese teile
hier ist gericht machen feuerzeuge ich
bin natürlich sehr geil wenn ich jetzt
mal eine schere nehmen einfach ein schaf
schere seht ihr diesen hier nimmt expect
beispielsweise jetzt schwarz wenn ich
hier auch hingehe sind die sind die
schafe auf schwarz ja auch schwarz und
wenn ich jetzt einfach mal dass tech
speck wechselt ihr einfach die sind alle
gleich die sind alle immer wenn man die
geschoren hat einfach weiß wenn ich das
beispielsweise hier nochmal mache bei
einem schwarzen schaf ist weiß darunter
ein weißes schaf ist weiß drunter und
wenn ich hier vorne mal ein graues
scharf nehmen ist auch weiß bruder das
heißt diese kleine fleckchen hier sind
immer irgendwie weiß ich weiß nicht
woran das liegt das ist eine gewisse
blöde sache weil die eigentlich wenn sie
pink sind sind sie eigentlich auch
komplett pink und ich hab einfach
hingestellt aber hey was für ein
krankheitsfall nur spaß sogar mit dem
shader hier sieht einfach dass die
vortex beck geil aus es ist unglaublich
cool da freunde kennt ja alle den
schneemann hier und der greift natürlich
auch nicht nur ganz normale mops an und
so also die feindlichen ob sondern
natürlich dementsprechend auch creeper
und wissen dass die krippe als
verteidigung machen die tripa machen
nicht irgendwie dass sie zurück
angreifen oder so sondern die laufen die
bringen sich quasi um die werden dann zu
kamikaze die laufen zum schneemann guckt
der schneemann attackiert den
triebwerkbauer denkt jetzt was mit pizza
ich glaubte man hin und will den jetzt
umbringen und der krieg erinnert an
einer passenden entfernung zum
schneemann ist ich glaube das ist grad
nun endlich langer fall der probieren
das ganze mal hier nochmal ich denke
dass es hier ein bisschen interessanter
weil jetzt näher aneinander sind auch
das ging jetzt sogar ein wenig zu
schnell ich zeig euch mal hier noch mal
ganz kurz und zwar wenn ich einen
schneemann habe und einen keeper dann
attackiert der schneemann halt den
propeller denken rest des teams spaß und
der keeper exponiert einfach und will
damit quasi den schneemann auch mit in
den tod reißen das gelingt zwar nicht
immer genau so wie es vorhin gesehen
habt aber der keeper will auf die
fall so nah wie möglich an den
schneemann und dann explodiert er auch
erst wenn er nahe genug dran ist und
zwar provoziert das ganze jetzt einfach
mal in dem ich das am scharf zwischen
schiebe warm und damit möchte der kripo
nämlich den schneemann umbringen soll
seine gegner tacke und es ist weg 30 40
3333 so freunde für den flip effekt hole
ich mir jetzt mal eben hier so'n und und
diesen hund gebe ich jetzt einen namen
ich nenne jetzt blödmann und wenn ich
jetzt den hund ganz normal mit dem
diamant stellt beispielsweise töte was
ich nicht benannt habe steht im chat
blödmann wurde von con kräfte erschlagen
das ist ja eigentlich recht logisch
allerdings wenn ich hier beispielsweise
mir mal so ein hund nehmen und ich töte
den jetzt beispielsweise mit meinem
bogen der p das heißt mein vater ist
übrigens vagina aber das ist egal sagen
wir der bogen heißt penis dann schieße
ich mal auf den hund drauf und wenn ihr
seht wenn der hund gleich stirbt ich
schaffen und in minecraft abzuschießen
das war auf jeden fall grad eine mega
coole sache weil ich habe vergessen dem
hund einen namen zu geben
da haben wir den blödmann und wenn ich
jetzt den hunden abschließe seht ihr
schon der blödmann ist im chat steht
sogar mit jenes erschossen also mit
diesem gegenstand mit dem ich ihn
erschossen das ist doppelt gemoppelt
weil eigentlich habe ich ihn ja mit
vagina erschossen also mit dem pfeil
also das ist wieder so ein doppelter
fake einerseits wenn ich einen hund
schieße töten quasi mit dem wenn ich
irgend ein mockup schieße für dich nicht
mit dem fall sondern mit meinem bogen
laut chat und wenn ich ganz normal
blödmann erschieße mit einem mit einem
gegenstand die ich genannt habe dann
wird er ebenfalls und angezeigter
freunde normalerweise würde die jetzt im
fünfeck sehen nur ich möchte wirklich an
dieser stelle nochmal sagen ich habe mir
echt gedachten guckt jetzt noch weiter
am 5
und ich hatte keinen bock darauf noch
nach dem fünften zuschauen weil es ist
einfach so eine durststrecke immer man
schaut sich dann um
wo sind denn noch packs wo hat mir dann
noch wenigen was zugesendet und ich weiß
viele von euch werden jetzt sagen ja wir
haben jedoch richtig viel zugesendet ich
habe mir sehr sehr viel davon
durchgelesen natürlich noch nicht alles
aber vieles davon wurde entweder schon
gesagt funktioniert nicht oder ist
einfach nur kacke sowas möchte ein wenig
vorstellen
deswegen möchte ich euch einfach sagen
freunde wenn ihr wollt wirklich dass
diese serie noch weiter fortgesetzt wird
ich habe auf jeden fall spaß dran aber
nicht wenn wir nicht weil sie so den
ganzen tag rum sitzung versuchen muss
sondern einfach dann schickt mir doch
bitte eure ganzen facts dir einfach
kennt und in die beschreibung dass wir
super lieb
ich wünsche ich wird so einer höhle man
minecraft leben entdeckt mit so viel
reisen da würde ich mich auf jeden fall
sehr darüber freuen und dann denke ich
dass auch nächsten dienstag an eine
weitere folge der minecraft rechts kommt
sonst würde ich sagen sehen uns erstmal
morgen wieder oder freitag bei den
command und so weiter und so fort wenn
es euch gefallen habe ich mich über die
bewertung von und wir sehen uns dann